في الذكرى السادسة والعشرين
لوفاة الأميرة ديانا المفاجئة،
نسمع الآن أشرطة صوتية لم نسمعها من قبل
بكلماتها الخاصة، وهي تكشف كيف أصيب
الأمير تشارلز الآن الملك تشارلز
بخيبة أمل عندما اكتشف أن
ابنهما الأصغر الأمير هاري لم يكن
فتاة
فاز بها زوجي  "حتى أنني لم أتحدث إلى أمي إلا قليلًا،
لأنه كان في فترة تعميد هاري،
ذهب تشارلز إلى أمي وقال إنك
تعلمين أنه كان محبطًا للغاية واعتقدنا
أنها ستكون فتاة، قطعت أمي
رأسه وقالت إنه يجب أن تدركي كم
أنت محظوظة بإنجاب طفل".  هذا أمر
طبيعي منذ ذلك اليوم، سقطت رصاصة
وهذا ما يفعله عندما
يرد عليه شخص ما، إذا جاز
التعبير،
تتذكر ديانا أيضًا اقتباسها السخيف من
زواجها من تشارلز وعلاقتها المضطربة
مع زوجة أبيها التي
كان قد كبر فيها و  لقد كان
مدرسًا في روضة أطفال ديانا وأعتبر الأمور
سخيفة قلت كل شيء وربما
أستطيع ذلك، وقال راين إنه ليس لديك أي
فكرة عن مقدار الألم الذي تسببت فيه والدتك لوالدك،
قلت إن الألم قد زاد، إنها كلمة واحدة
لا تعرف حتى كيفية الارتباط بها
وظيفتي وفي دوري أرى الناس يعانون
كما لم تراهم من قبل وتطلق على ذلك
الألم قلت إن لديك الكثير لتتعلمه، سجلت
ديانا هذا التسجيل الصوتي في التسعينيات
وسلمته سرًا إلى المؤلف
أندرو مورتون، وكانت هذه الأشرطة هي الأساس
من كتابه ديانا قصتها الحقيقية